[Music]
if the universe is full of stars why
doesn't it appear white and if it did
what would it look like with all the
black holes suddenly become visible and
if our sky was all white would we still
be able to see the stars this is what if
and here's what would happen if the
universe was white instead of black let
me break something to you
black is not a color as far as physics
is concerned by definition color is the
visible spectrum of light waves a black
object absorbs all the colors in the
spectrum making black an absence of any
color on the other hand white is a
mixture of all colors and it contains
all wavelengths of visible light color
is about our sensory perception of the
world but going back to the background
of the universe you could say it was
white once when the universe was born
from the Big Bang it didn't have any
stars to emit light it was opaque with a
hot soup of protons electrons and
neutrons after about three hundred
thousand years space cooled down and
those particles began pairing up into
atoms and molecules the universe became
transparent but to you it would appear
absolutely dark because not a single
light source had formed yet this was the
era of cosmic dark ages it ended when
the first stars started fusing hydrogen
into helium
those stars were up to 300 times more
massive than our Sun and a million times
brighter they shine for a few million
years before they exploded as supernovas
the growing radiation from those first
stars ionized hydrogen atoms split them
back into protons and electrons and
that's when the dark universe lit up
filled with ultraviolet protons so why
didn't it stay that way
why with all the new stars and new
galaxies is our night sky no longer
bright well that is Olbers paradox you
see if the universe appeared to be white
instead of black it would mean that it's
infinitely old infinitely big and static
at the same time that would make it a
different universe altogether we know
that our universe is just under 14
billion years old that might seem like a
long time but remember even light has
its speed limit we can only see stars
that are less than 14 billion light
years away from us the light from more
distant stars hasn't had the time to
reach earth yet as our universe keeps
expanding the distance between stars is
increasing too and as distant stars move
further away from us the wavelength of
their light increases and shifts towards
red until it becomes so long that the
human eye can't see it anymore
that's another reason for the black
background of the universe space is
filled with all kinds of radiation you
just can't see it and what about the
black holes well even if a very powerful
source of light illuminated our universe
you still wouldn't see any black holes
those things have such a strong gravity
that they don't emit any light and
therefore can never be visible black is
after all an absence of color it would
be cool to catch a black hole one day
and turn it into an infinite energy
source but that's a story for another
what if